virtual reality have you ever been to
words quite so able to make you excited
and also disappointing at the same time
well I guess possibly hoverboard bacon
coke and of course tinder date but still
for me at least VR takes the virtual
biscuit of excite appointment you see
the allure of transporting yourself into
a fully realized alternative reality by
simply donning a visor is just too
strong and while the promise of this
experience has been around for well
longer than I have
we're still not quite there but maybe
that's all about to change
the last two years has seen the R in VR
come to stand for return resurrection
and recombobulator that's not a word
actually it is Rican population know the
act of recombobulator of course now over
the course of the next month or two
reality check is going to dive deep into
the world of VR in a special three part
series covering the history rise and
future of this fascinating technology
part one where we begin today is all
about the history of virtual reality so
come with me as we discover where it all
began
why it faltered and how we ultimately
arrived at this virtual Renaissance
the year is 1965 Russian cosmonaut
Alexei Leonov has become the first
person to walk in space lyndon b johnson
is president of the USA and a man called
ivan sutherland are set in motion the
wheels of what we will ultimately call
virtual reality he did so with the
creation of the ultimate display the
world's first head monte display or hmd
lovingly nicknamed the sword of Damocles
due to its room-filling size this device
placed the user in a true virtual world
albeit a wireframe one but wait a minute
maybe that's not the true beginning of
our story you see if placing the user in
a virtual world is the ultimate goal of
VR then maybe we need to begin our story
about ten years earlier with the
creation of the sensor Rama its inventor
Morton Heilig conceived the creation of
an experienced Theatre in his 1955 paper
the cinema of the future basically a box
you could stick your head and watch a
movie and have all of your senses
stimulated by 1962 he even had a working
prototype able to display stereoscopic
3d images in a wide-angle view
provide body tilting play stereo sound
and also trigger blasts of wind and
aromas at specific points during each of
the five purpose-built short films
regardless of where we begin our story
though there's a long way to go from
either of these starting points to the
VR technology of today so let's take a
look at how we got from retro to rift
steady development of early VR tech
during the 60s and 70s was driven
chiefly by the US military's work on
vehicle simulators specialist teams at
NASA and also researchers at the
University of Utah this progress in
tandem with advancements in computer
graphics technology really began to gain
momentum in the 1980s and in 1985
something truly monumental happened I
was born and also a team at NASA made
something the virtual environment
workstation this next step in VR
consisted of two LCD TV displays
wide-angle stereoscopic optics and a
motorcycle helmet also the term virtual
reality was first coined by Lanier later
a member of the team involved in the
creation of the gloves designed for use
with the ve W now we can't really talk
about the history of virtual reality
without mentioning the inspirational
Randy Pausch Parrish is perhaps best
known for his wonderful and moving 2007
talk the last lecture really achieving
your childhood dreams which he delivered
shortly after receiving a terminal
diagnosis resulting from the spread of
his pancreatic cancer it really is a
wonderful video you'll be laughing one
minute on the brink of Tears the next
it's also a fantastic lesson in public
speaking and presenting just go and
watch it straight after this but what
did he have to do with virtual reality
well as well as working for Disney on
early VR projects he founded the
building virtual worlds course in 1998
at Carnegie Mellon University which he
taught for 10 years inspiring countless
students to work in the field and propel
a technology forward and speaking of the
90s that is when BR videogames began to
emerge the earliest publicly available
VR games came in the form of special
arcade machines in 1991 to 93 the
company virtuality group creates the
line of advanced VR machines with
stereoscopic 3d visuals and mind-blowing
276 by 372 resolution but success in
early games VR was rare Sega announced
Sega VR in 1991 and it was even
showcased at sea
and 93 however the console never
actually materialized as a retail
product despite reportedly having four
games developed specifically for it and
you know what this was probably for the
best as we all know what happened to the
VR console that was released a few years
later tada the Virtual Boy this 32-bit
tabletop 3d video game console developed
by Nintendo was marketed as the first
portable video game console capable of
displaying true 3d graphics which I
guess is true so long as you liked the
colors red and black oh you do well then
good news actually it was bad news
for a Nintendo at least the unit was a
commercial flop during part two its
price tag one hundred and seventy nine
dollars at launch which is about $250 in
today's money while not an outrageous
cost for a console per se this was still
a significant spend for something this
new and strange alongside this issue
customers just didn't like using it it
was nigh impossible to gain with the
thing in a comfortable position add to
that the lack of software support a
death knell for any budding system has
not a surprise the Virtual Boy wasn't
actual failure and in fact these three
problems that killed the Virtual Boy
cost lack of software support and
customer apathy epitomized the reasons
why VR in general failed to live up to
its promise in the 90s by the end of the
decade virtual reality in the world of
games at least had all but vanished from
the scene across forums and developer
events it was barely spoken of again
until that is the 1st of august 2012 and
the launch of a Kickstarter project for
a little device called oculus rift and
that is where part two of this series is
going to pick up in a few weeks as
always guys let me know what you thought
of this episode and the comments down
below or you can send me a tweet too at
Camp Franz Robb also if you think I
missed something in this episode or
there's something you'd like me to
mention in future shows about virtual
reality do send me a message oh and if
you want to check out my resource list
for this episode then follow the link on
screen now or click the link in the
description on YouTube to check out the
Biblio page I made for this episode see
you guys next week
you